wo ist ein
[Musik]
zum schluss müssen die leute nur noch
bestellen also kurz gesagt zuerst
entwickelt eine firma eine app für unser
angebot richtig und wir werden einen
flyer und eine website erstellen aber ja
die gerichte werden von den kunden
bestimmt über die app bestellt okay
leute bestellen über die app und dann
wird es mit jahres fahrrädern
ausgeliefert im prinzip ist das richtig
aber das besondere ist die leute können
ob sie eine fertige mahlzeit bestellen
wollen oder nur die zutaten meinst du
wirklich dass das angebot angenommen
wird
na klar außerdem wird in der app gezeigt
welche gerichtes für vegetarier oder
veganer gibt oder menschen mit
laktoseintoleranz darauf wird dann auch
geachtet
das habe ich so wirklich noch nicht
gesehen ja das ist super aber wozu
brauchen wir ein investor
ich meine so teuer ist das ganze noch
gar nicht wenn das konzept funktioniert
könnten andere restaurants einsteigen so
könnten wir in der ganzen stadt und
irgendwann vielleicht im ganzen land
liefern
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht
da kommen schon das ist unsere chance
dieser investor wann können wir den
treffen wenn du willst du zeit hast so
fort
[Musik]